المفاوضات التي يمكن ان تحقق انجازات
تاريخيه ونحن نعتمد على الدعم الذي يرمي
لتحقيق اهدافنا الاستراتيجيه
بحيث يتم ضمان بيئه امنه وهذا لا يحدث الا
من خلال
تكامل
حقيقي بين ضفتي الاطلسي وكنت قد طالبته
كافه الشركاء بالانخراط في عمليه تنفيذ
خطه السلام
المعنيه باوكرانيا
وشاطرنا بعض النقاط
وبعض
الاوجه المتعلقه بالمساعدات بحيث يمكن
النظر بخطه السلام لتحقيق السلام والنظام
العالمي وكل هذه الامور قد تم التشديد
عليها
بحيث تكون ضمن ميثاق الامم المتحده
لان كل دول العالم ترغبوا بان يتم تحقيق
السلام
وامل ان تستطيع اسبانيا ان تنضم الى هذه
الجهود العالميه التي ترمي الى تحقيق
السلسله وجعل الغزاه
يتحملون المسؤوليه عما اقترفوه في
اوكرانيا
وكنا قد تطرقنا في اجتماعنا الى اليه
التعويض التي يمكن تطبيقها
وانني ممتن لكم لايجاد الوقت للتطرق لكافه
هذه المواضيع هذا الامر كله
يعود الفضل فيه
اتفاق زعماء العالم
ورؤيتهم بام اعينهم
لنتائج
للنتائج التي خلفها العدوان الروسي
هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه
لبلادنا ولكافه دول العالم
ان نقدم الدعم والمساعده
من خلال ايجاد الاليه
للمساءله
انعدام العداله ولا بد من ايجاد بيئه امنه
لعوده المواطنين والبنى التحتيه هذه واحده
من القضايا التي تطرقنا اليها وخطه
التعافي السريعه لاوكرانيا
وكيفيه تسهيل اماكن التعليم واوجه العمل
كلها
مسائل مهمه تطرقنا اليها سوف تكون تاريخيا
لكافه العالم اشكركم على مفاوضتكم
على زيارتكم الثانيه التي تعد في غايه
الاهميه واشكر كل مواطن اسباني على
مساعدته وعلى حسن الضيافه للمواطنين
الاوكرانيين
والان الى الكلمه
الى كلمه رئيس اسبانيا شكرا جزيلا على
دعوتي للحضور الى كيف في هذا اليوم المهم
انني ممتن
لدعوه الى القدومي
التي تصادف
في ايام الذكرى السنويه الاولى لهذه الحرب
كما تعلمون اسبانيا قد عبرت عن دعمها
الكامل لاوكرانيا في مواجهه حرب بوتين
العدائيه
نشهد مره ثانيه
انعداما للاخلاقيات
وعرقله للنظام العالمي
بسبب هذه الحرب
وكنت قد كررت للرئيس سيدنسكي والدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بان نقف مع اسبانيا
وماضون في دعمكم طالما
سوف يكون الامر ضروريا واوكرانيا سوف
تنتصر
اسبانيا تدين باشد اللغه باشد الكلمات هذا
العدوان الروسي ولا يمكننا ان نقبل
ما اقترفته روسيا من جرائم